as the crisis in ukraine continues to
intensify so does the relentless war of
wars in and around the conflict
vladimir putin shocked many by saying
russia's invasion of ukraine has only
just begun one thing is for sure with
heavy shelling pounding residential
areas it's civilians who are paying the
deadly price the ukrainian side
meanwhile says it's seeking to amass and
arm a million troops
so unto the point we ask after capturing
large parts of donbass will putin have
an appetite for more
[Music]
[Music]
a warm welcome to to the point with
these guests today
lyanna fix is a political analyst
focusing on russia in eastern europe
maurice gatman is chief reporter with
the german magazine cicero
and joining us from bonn is my ukrainian
colleague roman gontarenko who works
with dw's russian language service
thank you so much to all of you for
joining us today lyanna i'd like to
start with you ukrainian president
volodymyr solenski is speaking of this
massive counter-offensive to regain
territories in the country's south is it
plausible is it even possible for
ukraine to do that
well ukraine obviously needs at this
point some kind of success and at the
moment it is it would be easier to
achieve these successes in the south
although it is still very difficult than
in the east where russia is basically
throwing all its artillery on the
ukrainian forces and pushing forwards
meter by meter kilometer per kilometer
at the same time it's also a tactical
decision to announce
this this plan to prevent that russia
will focus on all troops in the east but
also to um free some of the troops in
the east and to give russia the
opportunity to move to the south and
there to keep some forces focused in in
the south um but obviously with regard
to the weapons available to the
ukrainian army we need much more western
support to ukraine to make such an
offensive in the south successful we'll
get to the weapons in a minute i'd like
to get your opinion do you think that
ukraine can even do that with the
current capacities that they have
i think at the moment uh ukraine is not
capable of recapturing
gerson region for example
because it's one question to have one
million people who are ready to go and
it's another question to equip them
properly
i just have one example of a friend who
joined the armies several months ago
he's mainly equipped with
stuff that
friends donated to him
friends bought this
equipment
and of course it's a
a big operation uh against russians in
the herzone region who have fortified
their positions over the last months
it's a difficult area to do an offensive
operation and uh yes as you said ukraine
needs more than just soldiers to
recapture this area that's right that's
only one part before we ask roman about
um
the possibilities are i'd like to listen
to what the russian
president vladimir putin had to say
about that the war is just beginning
let's listen
we hear that they want to defeat us on
the battlefield what can i say
let them try
it's a tragedy for the ukrainian people
but it looks like that's where it's
heading
but everyone should know that we haven't
even started anything in earnest yet
so that we have russian presidents
saying that the war is just beginning
i'd like to have the reaction of roman
who's joining us from bonn who is the
russian president addressing here
well of course he's addressing um
ukraine he's addressing the west uh as
ukraine's um main support of for weapons
and
of course he's also addressing his
domestic public in russia so i think um
it is uh indeed a point where we can say
this war
is just at the beginning so this will be
very long conflict probably years ahead
of us and russia is really
holding back
some reserves it is using old soviet
weapons sending troops from
faraway regions
and
keeping all those uh best equipped
troops from moscow or saint petersburg
so where in the west of russia western
part of russia they are participating in
this war but not on a large scale so
russia is preparing for a war of
attrition we are seeing this war of
attrition happening and ukraine needs
much more weapons to be able to stand
for a long time to to be able to um try
and recapture maybe some uh cities in
the south at the moment i think uh you
can ukraine will be winning uh this this
at this moment if it can stop the
russian advance so uh stopping russians
in the south stopping them in the east
in donbass would be a victory for the
moment for ukraine i think and just to
add perhaps to that at the same time
it's also a strategic communication
operation as was said towards the west
to convey the impression well your
support is futile it doesn't make any
sense because we can throw as much
soldiers and as much materials into the
war as we want which is to some extent
of course overblown because russia had
some very heavy casualties 24 000
soldiers as estimated by by the british
side so this is also a communication
attempt and a propaganda attempt towards
the west to play into war fatigue to
play into the energy crisis into the
inflation
inflation problems in western countries
do you think it's working the propaganda
attempts to tell the west this will be a
long war it makes no sense for you to
support
to be unified with this solidarity
towards ukraine
well as i look at the german society for
example
i have the feeling that it's working
together with this inflation and energy
crisis that we see in our country
because the people for the first time
now they understand that the impact of
the war it's happening here
people will see over the next months the
energy prices rising uh
really a lot
and of course people will pose the
question to their government is it worth
isn't it worth maybe we need a
compromise with russia we heard these
voices over the last four months but
they will be stronger even over the next
months and
at this moment putin is sending the sign
we haven't started yet uh we can do much
more
uh of course i have the feeling that
this can work yeah
before we start talking about you just
mentioned energy price that's a really
big topic almost for another show let's
focus on the situation on the ground
with many saying that the war has just
started now in february but the war has
been going on for years and years so the
fighting in some areas of the dunba
since 2014 after the annexation of
crimea pro-russian separatists wanted
the eastern ukraine region to secede
from the rest of ukraine and russian
troops gradually advance in the donbas
with deadly consequences for the
civilians living there
a man's body is recovered from the
rubble of a multi-story apartment
building
neighbors looking on are shocked by the
rescue work in chasivjar in donetsk
oblast
all that remains of the high-rise is a
pile of rubble
during the night russian rockets hit the
building killing more than 40 residents
only a few survivors could be rescued
now we are always afraid afraid at night
and during the day because we never know
when something might happen to us
[Music]
a ukrainian soldier on home leave finds
his grandmother's body under the rubble
i'm at a loss for words
most of all i would like to kill putin
with seemingly unlimited supplies of
artillery and ammunition russia's war
machine appears to be slowly but
fiercely moving forward
meanwhile russia has conquered almost
the entire donbass region
what are russia's plans for the occupied
donbass
really terrible situation for the
civilians living there and they're
pounded by these russian missiles i'd
like to pass the question on to you
lyanna what are russia's plan for the
occupied region well what we see right
now is that russia is pursuing a de
facto annexation of these regions we
have politicians coming in we have
russian structures installed in these
regions ukrainian passports that are
taken away and replaced by russian
passports so that's a strategy that we
already know from the past um but what
is crucial here is and i think it's
really a rhetorical question to ask if
vladimir putin has the appetite for more
war he definitely has because we really
should not fall into this trap of
thinking well he just wants the donetsk
and the luchans regions and then he'll
be satisfied this is not a question
about this is not a war about territory
this is a war about existence about the
existence of ukraine as an independent
nation and russia is already now beyond
those territories very active beyond
those territories it will continue to
advance towards odessa if it has the
opportunity so the question of you know
can we appease russia if ukraine somehow
agrees to a ceasefire into those regions
remaining under russian control is
really
not a serious question this is not what
moscow is planning but for some it is
still a serious question saying that we
should talk to russia that they they
should be back again on the negotiation
table what do you think um is um there
have been so many red lines by the west
when it comes to russia and putin says i
can continue as long as i want to go how
is it possible to stop him
i think the only possibility is to show
strength
this is the only thing actually that
putin understands we have
seen this over the last decade where we
had several attempts of talking to putin
we had lots of politicians in the west
who said we have to find a compromise we
have to understand the russians but
unfortunately this didn't work and
those who haven't understood this on
february 24th
maybe it's their problem
putin only understands
strength and so we on the one hand we
have to strengthen ukraine
concerning the economy concerning the
military
uh on the other hand we have to find
solutions for or for our own um
economies uh this concerns uh mainly gas
because uh we are very
very much reliant on russian gas and
we have to
redesign our energy system over the
upcoming two years
not buying gas in other places after
these two years but somehow getting rid
of gas because if we are just buying gas
in other places this will keep the gas
prices on a high level and
this will
be very useful to putin so finding a
long-term solution to the dependence of
russian gas i'd like to ask roman about
the report that we just saw what are
russia's plans also considering that
russia wants now to have this fast
procedure for ukrainians to get a
russian passport so what is the plan on
the long term
well i agree with what rihanna has just
said so the plan is to destroy ukraine
as an independent state and russia is
keeping uh on this path and um
it is not going to um
uh to fulfill this uh gay um aim um
quickly so
russia is trying to um to cut ukraine in
pieces because it is just too big
uh to destroy um quickly and that is why
um russia has occupied some territories
and is now trying to integrate them
uh into russia by um by changing the
currency so you pay not in ukrainian but
in in russian ruble uh they are changing
the school programs they are sending
russian politicians russian military to
control and of course they are trying uh
to suppress uh the ukrainian opposition
or in those territories the the uh
ukrainians who are willing to fight
behind the front lines so this will take
some time but i think that uh russia is
um
probably um will continue to to occupy
much more territory by by by fall maybe
in winter and the west um is already
doing a lot and um what we have seen so
far
uh the west um is also facing a dilemma
if they are
providing ukraine with more deadly
weapons like those high mars
rocket launchers which are very
effective as we have seen in the last
few days um against russian ammunition
depots and command posts
um and then the west is asking the
question where is the red line for putin
when he will hit back and he threatened
to hit the
targets in in he didn't specify but he
said we could we could hit targets that
we haven't hit before and he probably
implied the ukrainian government maybe
the ukrainian defense minister so
targets in the ukrainian capital or
maybe targets in other major cities uh
military targets uh targets maybe
uh of uh where ukrainian command um is
so um it is it is very difficult for the
west on the one hand they want to help
they want to supply more weapons but
they have to find a way
not to cross a certain
line which is not seen of course nobody
knows where that line is not to um to
make this war much worse than it already
is
roman you mentioned the civil society
and also the ukrainian opposition in
those occupied territories and i would
like to take a look at um the people
living there the people living in these
places these occupied cities that
ukraine wants to retake and our ukraine
correspondent nick connolly spoke with
two citizens in the southern region
southern city of herzog due to security
concerns they wanted to stay anonymous
and this is what they had to say
at the beginning we all thought the
occupation would be over in a week
it was only a few months in
that we finally understood that the
russians were here to stay
it looks all fine and tidy in town
and peaceful except for the military
vehicles
but in fact
there are many places where russia
do that
things and of course you don't hear
about that
many people were kidnapped i see also
many
posters on the streets and on facebook
telling that this or that person is
missing
when the russians came we were expecting
things would be as bad as in mariupol
the fact that we can leave the house and
buy food
seems like a miracle
i'd say everyone is sure that the
ukrainians will liberate
the question is how and when
and um
we got the idea that
it should become a marathon rather than
a sprint
but how realistic is the ukrainian
army's planned reconquest of the south
and as russia wants to offer the
ukrainians a russian passport ukraine is
telling them to leave the area as
quickly as possible how can that work
maurice
i think there's a very important
psychological problem for example in
this region of kerson at the moment
because the longer it takes for ukraine
to take back these regions uh the more
these people get will get used to
russian occupation
of course ukraine is telling them
don't
collaborate with the russians we will
come back but
of course if you are a citizen of
herzone and you are waiting for months
and months and years for the ukraine to
come you have to somehow live your life
or
leave the regions
leave the region so
this is what we saw also in the donbass
region eight years ago uh the ukrainians
couldn't take these regions back and of
course people after some time
either they left the region or they
stayed there and they somehow adapted to
russian occupation so a longer process
they know that this war will continue
also for months if not years leanna what
will that make with the western
solidarity for ukraine we have d7
countries saying that they will support
ukraine as long as it takes do you think
that there is a unity to support ukraine
or that many countries are now saying
this is really getting difficult for us
as well
i think we still have unity at the
moment but the closer winter comes the
more urgent the energy problems become
the
louder will become calls that we need a
ceasefire and my concern is that at some
point moscow will play to these fears as
it does already now and for instance
propose
some kind of toxic proposal about well
once they've occupied perhaps the
entirety of the region of donetsk to
offer a ceasefire which obviously would
not be a credible ceasefire from the
russian side we know from russia's war
strategy in syria that they offer
ceasefires just to take a break for
their own forces and come back even
stronger but the temptation will be
there in the west
to uh to say well perhaps we should try
a ceasefire and
possibly to pressure ukraine ukraine has
learned its lesson from 2014 a ceasefire
doesn't work russia will come back and
even worse than it has been in the past
but for the west this will be a
challenge if we see this kind of
poisoned pill for moscow
roman liana just said ukraine learned
its lesson from 2014. what about the
west
well we are still not sure that the
lessons were properly learned because uh
germany when we speak about germany is
still having a huge problem with russian
gas something which maurice was moritz
was talking about so we the dependency
is so immense over 50 percent of
uh um german gas comes from russia
and
we cannot solve this problem here in
germany fast enough and ukraine needs a
germany actually to stop buying russian
gas because every dollar every euro that
germany pays for it goes then probably
to russian weapons to the russian army
and is then turned against ukraine
so uh there are still lessons to be
learned and and uh quickly
um i would like just a few words if i
may to the to the people leaving now in
the occupied territories in the south or
in the east in this it's a different uh
different story because much part of
donbass or some part of it was already
occupied in 2014
but as to the south it's a completely
new situation and nobody knows how
ukrainians living there those millions
of people will react in in in a few
months or in one year living under
russian occupation i presume that um as
long as russia is strong and can
suppress uh ukrainians living there and
trying to oppose the new russian regime
as long as long as russia is strong
there will be probably no no great
changes there but when russia is
weakened by western sanctions
then i think an uprising is possible but
we it is still too early to tell when
this will happen and under which certain
circumstances
rolling just mentioned the sanctions and
we have all this discussion when it
comes to nordstrom one they have the
annual maintenance we have turbine in in
canada they will now be sent to germany
and then to russia to
activate this gas pipeline again do you
think it's credible when the west says
we have the sanctions for russia but as
when they start affecting us more than
we say okay you they're not that
important anymore well there's a reason
why there are no sanctions on gas so far
and why there are oil sanctions which
will only come into place at the end of
the year and that is exactly the
dependency of the west on russian gas so
the idea is also when it comes to this
turbine it is to make clear that it is
russia which is cutting off the gas and
that germany is not sort of um is
not it's not the fold of the german
government and this is obviously
domestic communication towards the
german public if gas supplies from
russia get further cut it is a very
reactive strategy
it is not a proactive strategy of trying
to pressure moscow for instance through
caps on gas prices
but it is a strategy to fill the
storages and to try to outplay moscow
and i'm not sure who will have the upper
hand in this game i wanted to add that
maybe this story with a turbine it's
also was also done in this way to not
give moscow an extra argument in its
propaganda that
this is
why we don't supply gas to germany
anymore or to europe i want to add one
more thing to this gas question we see
in germany uh how difficult the
situation is concerning gas concerning
the gas prices
but of course germany is a strong
country economically financially
we must also look at other countries in
the european union especially in the
east countries like bulgaria who are
even more dependent on russian gas and
who are economically
much
more weak
how will they
come through this crisis
germany can pay extra money to its
citizens
to those groups of the population who
isn't
that rich but what will bulgaria do this
is a very difficult question and the
european union should address this
question now
we only have a few minutes left i would
like to if we go back to the question at
the beginning does putin have more
appetite for war i think we all agree
that he has that he will continue how
can this be stopped what should be the
signal that the west should send now to
say this is enough
i think the west needs to get into a
strategic planning when it comes to
weapon deliveries and to link weapon
deliveries to a clear war aim which
should be ideally on the greater scale
the pushing back russia to the
pre-invasion lines but if there are
smaller aims for instance retaking her
son
the weapon delivery should be it should
be
calibrated towards this aims rather than
coming at hog once the west has those
available so we need a strategic
planning what does ukraine need in three
months in six months also
because domestic industries and military
industries weapon industries need to
adapt to produce these amounts of
munition and of weapons
how do you see it roman how can this
hunger fall more that putin has be
stopped now what are the signals that
the west should send
well the signal should be that the west
is ready to take pain to help ukraine i
mean of course
by um by showing that it is ready to uh
to get rid of russian gas supplies as
soon as possible and probably sooner
that we think now at this moment
this is most important i think and it
should also continue to supply ukraine
with arm with weapons because this is
the only um the only thing that putin
understands strength and strength means
weapons and weapons and once again
weapons you mentioned the strength
already is there a sign something where
you say you the west really needs to do
that now quickly
i think
the west should
not only supply ukraine with weapons but
it should also train ukrainian soldiers
in the west and this is something that
is actually happening at the moment
already and this is a good sign because
it means that the west has a strategy
not only for weeks but for months a good
sign thank you so much moritz lyanna
groman also and all of you for watching
this show to the point if you have any
comments you can leave it on our email
or a comment on youtube thank you so
much
[Music]
you